بالعكس. وهذا كله كما ترى حكومة
وانتم متابعينا. برأيكم ماذا لو
لم يغزو الروس اوكرانيا؟ ما الذي
كان سيحدث عندها؟ فضلا وليس امرا
تهديدا وجوديا لروسيا وهناك قد
يجن جنون الدب الروسي ونرى اسلحة
الروس اوكرانيا حقا. هل كان كل
هذا ليحدث يرد الكرملين? كان
اصبح في الحدود الروسية فعلا.
وهذا يعني ان الحلف سينشر جنوده
اوكرانيا بنفسها. ولربما ياتي
الاوكران وقد اصبحوا ضمن حلف
للصواريخ التي تتساقط عليهم من
كل مكان. بل سيخرجون اسلحتهم.
سيحدث الاسوأ. فالغرب يريد دائما
ما هو اسوأ لروسيا بل ويحلم
انضمام كييف للناتو يعني اقتراب
الناتو من حدود روسيا. بل انه قد
الروس لو لم نغز اوكرانيا اولا
لجاء اليوم الذي تحاربنا
اصبحت عكسية. فازدهار اوكرانيا
قد يعني تراجعا لموسكو والعكس
المظلم بالنسبة للروس? يبدو ان
العلاقة بين روسيا واوكرانيا
حربها في اوكرانيا لك انت اليوم
تحارب لابقاء شبه جزيرة القرم
في مسعاهم هذا? لو لم يغزو بوتين
اوكرانيا لكان الوضع مختلفا
اليوم وبلا شك. لكن هل الى
الجانب المضيء ام الى الجانب
الناتو. فكيف لنا ان ننظر
لانفسنا عندها. فماذا لو لم يغزو
لانضمت اوكرانيا للناتو وعندها
فلنقرأ على العالم السلام.
يقول لهم بلوا عقوباتكم واشربوا
ميتها يا في مقال سابق اشار
معاناة انسانية ودمرت مدنا
باكملها. بل ودفعت ملايين
حرب نووية. يكفي ان نقول ببساطة
انها حرب ستمحو مظاهر الحياة من
باستمرار. ولم يكن امام الغرب
الا عقوبات اقتصادية لا تسمن ولا
الكرة الارضية. وستقلب عاليها
سافلها. وقد تنهي البشرية جمعاء.
وهناك دول عديدة تمتلك الكثير من
اسلحة الدمار الشامل ايضا. فضلا
اوكرانيا بضغط غربي وامريكي
تحاول استعادة القرم بشتى طرق.
عن امريكا التي تعادل قوة
اسلحتها ما لدى روسيا. انها
الروس الا تؤخذ منهم مرة اخرى
على الاقل لمدة ثمانية قرون. ظلت
الدمار الشامل تجب سماء الغرب
وامريكا. وعندها سنرى الاسلحة
بوتين الى الروس والاوكرانيين
على انهم شعب واحد. واشار الى ان
بانهيار روسيا كما انهار الاتحاد
السوفيتي يوما. فهل يفلح الغرب
تغير عندها. لكن ليس الى الاحسن
كما تظنون. فيرى بوتين ان خير
الشهيرة. اذا كان لا بد من الحرب
فاحرص على ان تكون اول من يضرب.
لكن تلك الضغوطات كانت ان تؤدي
الى مفاوضات مع روسيا وعند
ضمن اراضيها. مضت ثماني سنوات
على استعادة روسيا للقرم. وينوي
هو الناتو وامريكا؟ ام ان موسكو
تشترك في ذلك؟ لو لم تطلق موسكو
تغني من جوع. والامر من ذلك كله
ان معظم من يسقط في الحرب هم
بين عدم الخسارة الربح. لو لم
يبدأ بوتين الحرب في اوكرانيا
التوسع وضم اوكرانيا. تسببت
باشعال حرب غير ضرورية خلقت
الحرب العالمية يا سادة. واي حرب
سيخوضها العالم هذه المرة. انها
المفاوضات لابد من الاخذ
والعطاء. هناك اراد الروس ان
مدنيون ابرياء. فما هو ذنبهم?
احلام الناتو ورغبته الجامحة في
بوتين لم يكن اول من ضرب في
اوكرانيا فقط. بل ظل يضرب
الاوكراني للنزوح الى دول
مجاورة. فمن يتحمل ذنب هذا؟ هل
للهوية. ماذا لو? لو لم تغزو
روسيا اوكرانيا. لكان الوضع قد
حاولت امريكا فرض عقوبات
اقتصادية على روسيا لتتراجع عن
كازاكي. يا الهي الى اين المفر
عندها. فالغرب لن يقفوا متفرجين
النووية التي تعادل اضعافا
مضاعفة من قنبلتي هيروشيمانا
واسلحته هناك. وهل سيصمت الروس
على ذلك? تلك العملية ستعني
الداخل. هكذا يرى الكرملين
الوضع. وهم يستذكرون مقولة بوتين
العقوبات. وبوتين يشتهي المزيد
من الاراضي الاوكرانية. وكانه
الغرب افسد اوكرانيا واخرجها من
فلك روسيا من خلال تغيير قصري
ايديهم. وهناك يؤكد الروس ان لو
لم نغزو اوكرانيا لكنا اليوم
نطالب بالسيادة في شبه جزيرة
القرم. ويا لها من خطة ذكية جمعت
تكون المفاوضات على اوكرانيا
جميعها بدلا عن التفاوض عما في
ضم القرم لكن عين بوتين كانت على
اقليم دومباص. وليس السيطرة على
وازبدت. لكن اذن الاوكرانيين
كانت صم تجاه تحذيرات الروس.
الثماني التي تلت ذلك. ظلت روسيا
تحذر اوكرانيا والغرب من مغبة
اوكرانيا باكملها. عن اي خيال
نتحدث يا سادة. الغرب يفرض
وسيلة للدفاع هي الهجوم. فلولا
يهاجم الناتو واحلامه شرق
اوروبا. لكان زعيم روسيا اليوم
يدافع داخل اراضيه وعلى حدوده من
العاصمة كييف الى اقصاء رئيس
صديق لروسيا بعد ان رفض التوقيع
في اوائل عام الفين واربعة عشر.
ادت الاحتجاجات الشعبية في
توسع الناتو بالقرب من حدودها.
لكن دون جدوى. حذرت وهددت وارعدت
الى التحالف العسكري الغربي هو
عمل عدائي وتهديد خطير لروسيا.
موسكو وقامت بضم شبه جزيرة القرم
الاوكرانية واثارة تمرد انفصالي
لروسيا. هل يقوى الناتو على
مواجهة كهذه امام الدب يرد بوتين
على اتفاقية شراكة مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي. جاء الرد سريعا من
ان توسع الناتو يمثل تهديدا
وجوديا. واحتمال انضمام اوكرانيا
الايام في المستقبل البعيد.
متجاوزا الخط الاحمر بالنسبة
سنوات اعلن الحلف عن نيته عرض
عضويته على اوكرانيا في يوم من
السوفيتية السابقة استونيا
ولاتيفيا ولاتوانيا بعد اربع
شرقي اوكرانيا سيطر على جزء من
منطقة الدمباص. في السنوات
الشيوعي. في عام الفين واربعة
اضاف الناتو جمهوريات البلطيق
تتهاوى. بعد انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي. توغل الناتو شرقا.
وتسعين. وهو معلم تحول الى ناقوس
موت للقوة العظمى التي كانت
وانضمت الى معظم دول اوروبا
الشرقية التي كانت في المدار
ننتقل في دقائق هذا هيا بنا يا
رفاق. بداية القصة. كانت
لصالح الاستقلال في استفتاء
ديمقراطي عام الف وتسعمائة وواحد
الناتو؟ هل كان ذلك ليشكل تهديدا
خطيرا على روسيا كما يقول
الكرملين لنعرف المزيد في
الاجابة على هذه الاسئلة؟ دعونا
اوكرانيا حجر الزاوية في الاتحاد
السوفيتي حتى صوتت باغلبية ساحقة
كييف? وفق اهوائها. ما الذي كان
سيحدث عندها؟ وكيف سيكون الوضع
مهلا. ماذا لو لم تغزو موسكو
اوكرانيا? وماذا لو تركت روسيا
ضعوا اجاباتكم في التعليقات.
تهديدا مباشرا على المواطنين
الروس. فماذا لو نجحت مخططات
اليوم؟ يقول الكرملين انما يخطط
له الناتو في اوكرانيا يشكل
السنين بنقل الناتو الى حدودنا
والغاء ثقافتنا. قاموا بترهيبنا
لسنوات عديدة. لكن ردنا سيكون
قاسيا وحازما. وعليهم ان يخافوا
من غضب الدب الروسي. هكذا قالها
الروس قبل غزوهم لاوكرانيا. لكن
اوكرانيا وحلفاؤها بما في ذلك
بريطانيا يهددون روسيا منذ عشرات